so Humphrey back in the States yeah
still over there what's he doing
sweeping up all just the confetti they
make him sweep it all up
um
no he's staying for the parade the uh
Rob's flying back for tomorrow yeah and
then
um he also his passport is expired oh
[__] and when he he told me when he was
leaving um just so you know my
passport's gonna expire while I'm over
there but it's okay because I'll just
get an appointment and get a new one
then landed in the UK went to go make an
appointment found out that the passport
office was striking for eight weeks
so there's no appointments he can't get
a new so he's there with without a
passport and so when the passport open
Office reopens
he'll then get a passport and then he
can come back but until then he's just
over there and he's too big to smuggle
back yeah you can fit him in a suitcase
today I don't know we don't know we
don't oh we don't know
we don't know whether it becomes it or
not one thing we could do is we could I
love a good mystery as I recall uh from
our last uh podcast I don't think he is
going to be here today yeah that's what
I thought I think he's going to be
absent so no one knows it's unknowable
what his schedule and I'm going to text
him how about that
this will be good this is drama for the
beginning of the podcast
[Music]
how was your weekend Glenn
um
that good huh
I don't remember what happened
yeah it was pretty unmemorable clearly
um
I think it was fine
[Laughter]
did you get another dog didn't get
another dog dude thank God I went and
saw uh
Evil Dead rise on Saturday night that
was a lot of fun was it good a lot of
fun
did you watch something very deep today
you know
did you see Pearl no I saw the first
movie X or whatever I saw that one but I
haven't seen Pearl which is a ton of fun
sequel is it okay it felt like it was
part of a bigger overall thing which I
think it is gosh have you guys seen the
movie Barbarian I got it don't tell me
anything about it oh boy that's my watch
list yeah buddy what okay enjoy
it's a horror film oh I don't know um
you don't watch scary movies ever
not really no really yeah I I like
reading how do you feel things then
well I feel scared all the time so I
don't see the needs oh yes mimic it and
yeah you're in fight or flight all the
time so I'm just always there so you're
the same reason I don't do roller
coasters because I'm like why do you
want to feel like you're about to die at
any moment
constantly that like Dread
um but no I I don't know I just get
easily scared my brain I since I was a
kid like whatever scary movie I would
just replay it like in dreams and stuff
it my brain locks in on stuff so I'm
just like let's not put what about like
The Shining oh I've seen The Shining
yeah I will watch like watch something
privacy horror movies if that makes
sense like things that are elevated like
I I don't want like if it's just like
yeah just pure just kind of like lazy
like jump scares and like I don't like
to get out which was amazing if I hear
that it's like more about the movie than
the horror aspect but I just couldn't I
would I would put the Exorcist in that
category sure it's a phenomenal oh
really yeah look it's scary as [__] and
it will it could [__] you up Barbarian I
I mean I gotta see I put up I put that
up there with I put that up there with
some of the better horror films I've
ever seen uh Evil Dead rise very much in
line with like the Evil Dead movies
which I'm a huge fan is it still
starring um what's his name Bruce
Campbell Bruce Campbell yeah yeah thank
you Bruce Campbell who played uh Ash in
uh the original Evil Dead trilogy
well Glenn it's nice
I think that uh we're not gonna be
seeing Rob mcelhenney today I think he I
don't know he's too good for us now or
two good verse today well well yeah two
good too good to even let us know
whether or not he's gonna be I think
that he did let us know as I recall I
remember thinking oh the next one we're
doing without him so I think he did tell
us possibly I certainly probably wasn't
listening I'm weirdly the but usually
you would know this I think but no one
no I think he did say yeah I believe he
did I believe he did so this is gonna
that's a shame because he's pretty funny
in this episode of Television but we
don't have to diver in the episode we
could no let's talk about horror films
we talk about horror films
talk about the absence of our friend can
I ask actually what would are there any
other horror films that you would put in
the category of artsy as you put it uh
like sort of like really great
filmmaking and therefore I would watch
it even though it's a horror
films any off the top of my head though
right now did you watch the ring no I
didn't see them the Ring's great the rig
was great but but that movie that movie
Jaws
I would think that would be considered a
horror film a horror film back in the
day I think it was considered a horror
film yeah yeah I mean now this film
four of us gotta get more of a fish
movie right yeah
well uh
um did you guys want to talk about this
episode today World Series defense yeah
sure we can yeah we can jump into
talking about this episode all right
World Series defense Megan do you want
to recap this episode for our listeners
at home and our viewers or crepolas
yeah the structure I appreciated you
trying to uphold it when I wasn't here I
tried yeah yeah
um okay so season five episode six the
World Series defense aired on October
22nd 2009 it was written by David
Hornsby and directed by Randall Einhorn
special guest stars Patricia Belcher
played the Judge John ponzio Dennis
Hogan and Dennis Hart yeah yeah and in
this one the gang describes the trials
and tribulations they went through
during game five of the World Series
hoping the judge will clear them of all
the citations they received
okay first of all
let's
I want to take a moment to talk about
John ponzio's performance so he is in in
the Philly frenetic costume and we
couldn't say fanatic that was like major
league baseball I was like nope sorry
you can't say fanatic so we called him
the Philly frenetic yeah and we also
couldn't say the holiday ends but then
you couldn't help yourself at the end of
the episode and you know what
in my counter suit uh Charlie Kelly
versus Major League Baseball
all right first of all I had to call him
the frenetic his name's The Fanatic but
you know I'm gonna get sued by Major
League Baseball if I call him the
fanatic and let's talk about steroids
can we talk about steroids can we talk
about steroid abuses [__] it's
ruining a game it's ruining it yeah yeah
you had to [__] call it out which I
love so at the end of the episode I call
it out we couldn't even call him this
and somehow we got that in and that was
fine
um wow we got away with that and
something I think that we started doing
later in life was just like we're just
gonna do it and it's just gonna be fine
um but uh so so ponzio
kills it and why don't you tell people
who pawns so okay John ponzio uh has had
the position of he's an actor but he's
also had the position of of stand-in uh
which is often when they're letting us
scene a performer stands on the actor's
Mark and they kind of uh they go through
the scenes they sort of perform the
scenes while the cinematographer is
lighting the scene and the well now this
might be interesting to people because I
think many people maybe don't know the
process of the the usual processes the
very first thing that happens is the
actors get called to set with the
director and they do uh what's called a
closed rehearsal with just the actors
and the director and maybe a few key
people uh that are making decisions
about how the scene's going to go and
the stand-ins are also watching the
rehearsal so that they can see what we
did in the rehearsal so uh then when
rehearsals over we leave to go get
finished in hair and makeup learn our
lines you know make phone calls
masturbate whatever it is that we need
to do uh to get ready for the the you
know the actual times is put on a
costume uh it might be putting on fake
bruises
I'm taking supplements and it's Glenn
you're in a major supplement routine
yeah I'm in the midst I mean in phase
three of my supplement routine I'm just
choking down pills
trying to make myself feel better
um and and while all that's happening
the stand-ins are walking through the
marks with the camera people and the
lighting people so that they can light
the scene it's so that when we show up
to set we don't throw a fit yeah and go
and go why wasn't this worked out with
my stand-in and various things like that
you know I was in the middle of
masturbating and you you know or
whatever it is yeah you know now uh
oftentimes uh you know we get to set uh
before that was all done and watch the
run through once or twice with the
stand-ins especially earlier on in the
show
um right just to make sure everything
was kind of uh
looking how we wanted it to look
um and we picked up on that John ponzio
was always excellent he's bringing us
he's always bringing it sometimes most
of the time the stand-ins are uh are
actors as well sometimes they have
sometimes they're not no they have no
aspirations of of becoming performers
and this is something that they do on
the side yeah my stand in Adam is
actually a brilliant musician so you
know his focuses music but uh so ponzio
who stood in for Rob uh
he was always great in in the
run-throughs
um so every now and then we would have
him play a role if we needed a guy who
said a thing or we needed a character in
a costume do you remember his first role
was this first one the uh on in mac and
Dennis breakup or is the waiter no
before he had something before that what
was his first one we had all the
stand-ins
in season three uh the gang gets whacked
I can't remember if it's part one or
part two but it's it's when you guys are
on the streets gumming the cocaine and
you run into Cricket oh yes and the
three and those three people business
people walk by and give him some loose
change that was all the stand-ins yeah
was in that crew look they let you
become a priest again huh
congratulations Mr Reverend amen how you
doing man hey keep your head up for
heaven hey keep the faith bless you and
John ponzio's been with us since almost
the beginning if not the very beginning
we'd have to double check that pretty
darn near it if not a lot of a lot of
the other standings have sort of come
and gone and his sister has done 80 work
yeah Carla's sister who also works
behind the scenes anyway so
John volunteered to be the frenetic and
I was watching it I was like man he
really nailed it because we had some uh
mascot work this season coming up and
it's tough
it's tough to
get a performance that reads through
that suit yeah and
you're watching that assuming like
that's the guy who does the thing he has
the whole bit the little like yawning
thing he does where he's patting his
nose or whatever he does a great job he
nailed it yeah even his timing when you
when you ask him like are you are you
messing with me are you are you taking
me seriously or whatever and there's
like this little pause and then he does
the time thing yeah it's like yeah and
then and by the way the the rhythm of
your punching yeah it's like that's also
great because like the second he does it
you smack him in the face and then you
punch him in the chest twice there's
something about the rhythm of that yeah
the timing of it is very funny it really
works well and then you you cut to Hogan
and heart uh who are robbed it sounds
like a comedy dude yeah they do that so
Rob's two friends that were in uh uh the
episode with Carmen was cancer Charlie's
cancer where Rob punches Carmen and they
say is that a hate crime and then they
they say yeah that's a hate crime they
pound him this was a call back to those
two they were construction workers at
the time they look like construction
workers yeah
um Rob why did you tell us about Hogan
and heart a little bit Yeah Rob where
where'd you meet those guys tell us a
little bit about your history with those
guys
that's a delight uh yeah I think that's
a great story
um
foreign
that's so great Rob
all right killing it all right don't big
league me not here man don't Piggly look
I'm trying to have a conversation with
the man behind the mask and I feel like
you're big licking me dude are you
taking me seriously
there it is
that guy's beating on the frenetic
dude is that a hate crime no it's not a
hate crime you want to hammers this
anyway definitely
that great Philly accent you can't you
know that's authentic not acting yeah
you want a Hammer's ass anyway anyway I
can't do it uh those guys are so funny
man they're great I love that I love
that they're hilarious and they they
nailed it uh in that performance
um it was up to that point for me
honestly like sadly it was my biggest
laugh was there was their exchange like
should we pound him anyway my biggest
laugh
lifts up the the tent and the amount of
smoke that comes out from under it I've
forgotten about and it caught me off
guard he wrote something mine was so
quick which was just you Charlie handing
Dennis papers he doesn't know oh yeah
I I clearly laughed towards the very end
yeah and the second time the second
round of that yeah right at the very end
yeah
your reaction gets me and I have to look
down because I'm laughing I love it
because we play it so I'm trying to play
it so real well the reason I was it's a
good bit but it's also one of those
things where like
it wasn't hard for me to play it real
because you didn't tell me you were
gonna do that oh you just started doing
it yeah yeah so it was actually mildly
irritating to me like I knew it was
funny but like but I'm trying to
remember my lines I'm trying to do my
lines and you're you're you know handing
me papers and it was actually like yeah
so I just kind of leaned into the like
whatever little bit of it was actually
kind of irritating to me which I
probably picked up on and then yeah
[Laughter]
um switch a paper with a different paper
perhaps you want this one perhaps these
notes you need
um and uh Patricia who plays the judge
yeah oh man is exceptional that was so
funny and she I got the I had the
pleasure of working with her a couple
times again on AP Bio oh really yeah she
plays the school superintendent on the
show so she would come in for a couple
episodes here and she was just and she
remembered working on Sunny with us even
though by the time I'd worked worked
with her on AP Bio it had been almost a
solid 10 years since since she had done
that but she remembered it and she had a
really good time and yeah she's just
she's lovely and a great performer
actions of the two
he's not typing very quickly the
shorthand she's getting the gist I don't
appreciate being paraphrased now I
choose my words very deliberately get
back to your case this also is the first
time I think we're discussing a random
line or directed episode is that correct
it can't be I thought he did one already
but he has done he I don't think it was
the first oh no wait a minute did he not
start working uh with us until season
five yeah season five was was his first
year okay so I don't think we've talked
that much about Randall is it Randall
brought
um
scale to the show in a way that we
hadn't done he was not cutting the
corners that we were used to cutting in
terms of like okay in this particular
episode normally we'd be like well we
can't show the stadium because yeah
obviously we're not gonna and here's
what I was trying to remember watching
that it's the first time you see the
shot the stadium is empty so obviously
we're saying this is before people have
entered the stadium later in the episode
The Stadium's full yeah did we shoot
that during a game of the full Stadium
or did we do a CGI put people in I
cannot remember let me tell you
something
I don't know
I don't remember either God damn it
okay Rob will remember because this is
the kind of stuff Rob remembers yeah
um
no [__] okay so his first episode was
the gang exploits the mortgage crisis
which was but it was this year that
randomly
which we have discussed we have
discussed that one right
um but yeah bringing I mean the the
scale of it he did it in such a way that
it didn't it didn't it could force us to
work longer days necessarily we're just
as fast yeah uh but like certain things
he was very ambitious he was very
ambitious and he was a little pushier
with us in the way that Adias was in the
second season he he pushed us a little
bit
um and we fought him on it and I'm glad
he pushed us yeah sometimes I think you
got to be a little pushy with us
otherwise we're gonna you know we're
gonna
maybe in terms of his vision okay uh
which sometimes we were like I don't see
it that way
um
and probably because he was seeing more
scale than we were used to doing on the
show right so and I think normally our
response would be like you don't really
need to see the stadium you don't really
it's it's fine like we we you you know
we're there we don't need to do a whole
thing you know but he would insist on on
those things and and I think for the
betterment of the uh episodes well yeah
because it it started to open up
possibilities for us right where from a
writing standpoint where you're getting
to the point where you're writing
yourself
uh into Corners because you say well we
just can't do x y z it opens up certain
story lines we're like well maybe we
actually could pull this thing off and
filling a stadium full of people is
really tricky to do
um I think that that's CGI people in in
in the shot in the second shot we're
doing CGI back then dude but I think it
would have been so chaotic to film
during a game and it's far away the
speed at which we move
we weren't we wouldn't shoot that
sequence with an empty stadium and then
come back at the end of the day when the
stadium was full to shoot the next scene
right we would be like this is our
location we got to get in and out Meg
maybe we can maybe you want to call uh
get Randall on the Einhorn
I was gonna text you lewini actually do
you think he would know if you did post
on that yeah Jeff might know now Einhorn
uh as I if I'm not mistaken
is also uh what Germans call unic a
unicorn
there's a there's a little movie yeah
yeah hang on so you got multiple things
to look up here is one and the horn is
horn well so so Germans call unicorns
Einhorn
and I know this because there's a there
was a great great animated film from the
80s called called The Last Unicorn
do you know this movie yes I remember
that it's weirdly kind of scary it
really scared me as a kid but it's a
great little fantasy movie Jeff Bridges
plays the prince in that movie and he
sings
and it's so interesting to hear him
singing and uh and uh I believe the band
America did a lot of the music for it
which is like seems incongruous but the
sorry just real quick the German title
of that film and the only reason I know
this is because I my my sister and I
were obsessed with that movie as kids
and I wanted to get her the soundtrack
to that movie but you couldn't get it in
America but you could get it in Germany
and the movie was called Einhorn
The Last Unicorn wow something like that
um
LSD culture was still heavily like
slipping into kids art in in our
childhood like because like fraggle
rocks and stuff yeah or like um
The Hobbit cartoon trippy trippy Rankin
bass even like certain like I don't know
if it was electric company or Sesame
Street stuff like remember the little
girl who's like trying to remember she's
like a loaf of bread a stick of butter
oh yeah quarter milk yep like I watched
somehow I saw that recently and I was
like this it's trippy it's like an acid
trip like the mother's like showing up
in her brand like loaf of bread yeah and
then she can't remember the third eye
then she can't remember it yeah there
was a lot of that trippy ass [__]
um uh I love those old Brank and bass uh
I mean those are the guys that did like
all the um you know the the the the
claymation stuff but like um uh Rudolph
and Frosty the Snowman that's all Rank
and bass yeah and they did that first uh
uh Hobbit movie which is terrific you
can tell like this I think yeah it's
fantastic you can tell like difference
of like the drugs like so like
everyone's like smoking weed
eat it started so we get like Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles
it comes in the system and there's like
so you know like the turtle's in the
sewer dude and like oh like their boss
is like a rat and uh they love pizza
guys it's NBA Finals time as soon as
football ends you've got uh you got
March Madness
um you got a horse racer too you know a
couple of golf tournaments basically
basically a month of people you know in
in the South uh wearing pastels and then
uh boom NBA playoffs and uh and the NBA
finals and after that
baseball comes back or whatever well I
I'm here because
because it's artery to scrounge up some
um
table fun money we are you doing you
scalping tickets outside of Arenas still
are you still doing that buddy I've told
you a juice is not worth the score no no
I'm off that no no this is just some
like side action I got going on you know
what I mean I made a decent penny in
boiled denims I drop all that into
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NBA they're tied
in together man that's so great that you
give back like that some days I do yeah
and some days I make a even decenter
penny back you know a new customer can
place a five dollar bet and score two
hundred dollars in uh bonus bets
instantly plus all customers can take a
shot at an even bigger payout with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
just download the draftking Sportsbook
app and use the code always and boom
you're in business man oh man that kind
of makes me want to put a bet on a game
and then go to it so Charlie do you have
any of those scalp tickets anymore are
you really out of that game
you guys know it's the worst
it's it's washing your dishes after you
cook you know oh God you know you're
done and you gotta wash everything of
course man I hate it I leave the dishes
there out for so long and then I get
angry at this dishes and then I get
angry at myself actually just takes like
10 seconds guys you just wash them off
you put them in the dishwasher wait what
what are you talking about what about
all the the pots and pans and the
cooking supplies those are things that
yeah I don't use cooking supplies
because I use factor which is America's
number one ready to eat meal kit I pop
in one of their fresh never Frozen
entrees into the microwave and I have a
delicious well-proportioned meal ready
in two minutes so there's no cleanup
afterwards I'm just done I just fridge
microwave recycling so you're not using
like an on-air fryer or anything like
that you're not using a deep fryer
you're not deep frying a turkey you're
not going to the grocery store you're
not doing any of this you're not
shopping yeah I only have so much free
time so I figure why should I waste any
of it you know like shopping shopping
prepping cleaning
um that's why I personally love Factor
especially in the summer because you
know in the summer my schedule gets real
busy this is great okay so you guys have
convinced me I'm never cooking again and
uh glennless joined factor and uh let's
leave this kitchen and Dish stress
behind us if you head to factormeals.com
sunny40 and use the code sunny40 to get
40 off your first box yep that's code
sunny40 at factormeals.com
sunny40 to get 40 off your first box
[Music]
foreign
yeah there's another thing you guys
didn't sell and make money off of I was
thinking the exact same thing when I was
watching the episode I'm like there's
another thing we could have capitalized
on Riot punch Riot punch we could we had
wine in a can imagine if we had done
wine in a can right and that had done
fairly well and then we did followed it
up with Riot Punch cover all your cover
all your business for all the different
customers you know yeah and then done a
sunny lager and we could be so rich
right now instead of just kind of Rich
yeah Rye punch was like uh ever clear
and Gatorade is that what the pretty
much yeah like ever clear with
electrolytes
right yeah
[Laughter]
um so this episode was this like it
seems so much of it is about or it comes
out of the fact that you couldn't be
wearing like Philly's merch yeah you
couldn't be talking about the fanatic
was that like did you guys decide oh we
want to do something about the fact that
they won the World Series but we really
can't so then the episode becomes kind
of about that as well yes yeah that's
what happens you know what I I actually
forgot that we can't wear the merch
watching the episode so I didn't really
they did a pretty good thing because um
Caitlyn's outfit is so close I feel like
it smoothing it over from even the
frenetics shirt is like a made-up
looking thing and um yeah we gotta give
Sabrina Rosen a lot of crap about our
costume designer on the show also like
the red eyeball thing after they go on
the bug bomb thing so this was something
that we were
like Leah uh our makeup artist
leave outro but those like red eyes are
so effective but like what was we were
putting like red eye drops in yeah it's
not very comfortable it's like it's this
kind of stuff that yeah it's like
they say it's like safe to go in your
eyes it doesn't feel safe we did it
again in the episode with um country
macro it looks really good it's you guys
look so funny in that when you're
smoking weed and you're eating out of
those chips
going back to like scale though like
even tenting the whole building which
Einhorn you know was like no we'll get a
building and we'll tent it versus like
before we probably would have like cut a
corner and been like well we can't
actually see the building tented but
we've made it I don't know yeah maybe
it's possible yeah it was funny you guys
lifting up a thing and like going it
sold it just enough yeah like you
getting underneath the the sheet um I
sort of feel like when Danny crawls in
though the smoke looked to me like that
was CGI right it was CG yeah so we had
some in this episode which makes me
think that the uh the crowd was also CGI
but right well I mean those two yeah I
mean I guess it wouldn't be that
difficult to CGI way way way in the
distance than you know to do some smoke
but you're right the second time when he
actually goes in that smoke is not real
that was that was like CGI smoke it was
like because some like thing where
you're like he can't crawl into the
smoke machine or like a union rules yeah
possibly
um but then we had real smoke and when
they actually go into the hallway yeah
the scene of them in the hallway
okay here's here's another example of a
shot that I think we would often Knicks
we'd be like ah you don't need that shot
but I love it it's a great shot so
there's the obvious the obvious great
shot of all the close-ups which swing
between uh Caitlyn Danny and Rob doing
the wretching uh which I think we cut
together multiple takes of it because it
was so funny and we just wanted to keep
it going I remember pushing for that
shot yes yes very Charlie I was like I
want to get up in their faces and I want
to swing around I remember uh Rob I feel
like you didn't want to do it because
you were like you know it's a lot to
Wretch like that was that
[Laughter]
someone was like I don't know how to do
it I was like I think it's gonna be but
I know that's what I'm talking about the
shot I'm talking about is the shot the
very last shot before we cut to
commercial which is the floor shot it's
not wide wide but yeah it's the it's the
kind of wider shot where the camera is
basically on the floor yeah and that's
the kind of thing that somebody would
normally propose to us and we'd be like
ah yeah you don't need it I need it
it's good it's good I mean yeah let's
let's watch it
[Music]
why is that so funny Caitlyn
so this is the shot I'm talking about
yeah yeah it's a good shot yeah it's a
great it's a great shot and I feel like
that's the kind of thing that we would
often just be like yeah you don't need
it and and I'm so glad we got it but
like I'm so glad it's so nice to work
with uh actors who are willing to make
themselves that wretched and ugly you
know what I mean and just just be it's
essential for a comedy because you gotta
dig the life out of it and if you're
like not willing to
make yourself
go to the extremes which life does it
just feels I don't know yeah it can't
always be pretty so as we're learning
lessons uh on this podcast as as we
often are teaching lessons you can't
always be pretty sometimes you just
gotta be ugly
sometimes you just gotta get on the
floor and wretch sometimes you just
gotta be and the more you wretch the
better the scene I got hammered so hard
yeah well you deserve it [__] Charlie
who hammered you just some overly
passionate Village fans who do you think
and hold on you're getting hammered by
Philly fans is reminding me of something
there is a secret tunnel between the
stadium and the audience I know dude I
was telling this guy about the tunnel it
does make things so much funnier when
you have to like get around it like um
allity in like the fact that you're all
saying allity and that the judge even
says it at the end are you telling me
you all found a dungeon at the bottom of
the Holiday Inn yeah yeah we could
another that's another one right yeah we
called it the Holiday Inn because you
couldn't call it the Holiday Inn yeah
yeah
that was just kind of funny yeah I also
love the uh when we do finally go to the
Holiday Inn and we're trying to find the
the tunnel that leads from the holiday
into the stadium
um you know when we get into that
laundry room yeah and Scooby-Doo you
know there's always some kind of okay or
whatever like we're not I love the line
of like can we not base our decisions on
things that either did or didn't happen
in episodes of Scooby-Doo that is great
yeah and then like the whole discussion
of the Charlie one too Charlie
describing the Charlie one two which is
just jumping out in front of a car yeah
um but you want to give it for the car
too you threaten the zoom yeah
then Dennis being like well it's called
The Charlie one too so you should do it
and you saying that the next one might
be your last yeah yeah I've done it too
many times that works pretty well like
yeah it it looks like you get drilled by
that thing
um yep just CL just a very simple
optical illusion of me uh you know just
I was behind them I was wasn't even like
in line basically the car was here and I
was like here but you know as it pulls
up it looks like it's it looks like it's
hitting me yeah it's pretty good and
then this also is Rob's introduction to
uh the his fascination with Chase Utley
yep how did you pick Chase Utley was it
just like at random did he already love
Chase Utley and wanted to be his friend
and manifest that the Universe I think
no what is funny actually though that uh
that at the time none of us knew no we
didn't know Chase yeah we didn't know
him at all no he was just a famous
baseball player yeah I mean he just uh
was a really great player and it just
seemed funny that Rob was upset handsome
guy yeah yeah
um yeah he's an exceptional baseball
player yeah uh
yeah that letter though that her
delivery of that letter is so funny yeah
her reading it I'll read it yeah read it
dear Chase oh [__] they're stickers oh
my god oh let's Jazz it up yeah you sure
do you want to make it you sure do
your Chase I feel like I can call you
chase because you and me are so much
alike
really I would love to meet you someday
it would be great to have a catch I know
I can't throw as fast as you but I think
you would be impressed with my speed
I love your hair you run fast did you
have a good relationship with your
father me neither
these are all things we can talk about
and more I know you have not been
getting my letters because I know you
would write back if you did and I hope
you write back this time and we get to
be good friends I am sure our
relationship would be a real home run
yeah
I remember working on that letter I
remember uh
writing the the me neither part like
just thinking that it was funny that Rob
just like answers that for him answers
for it
it's also funny that like Mac has to uh
either he fully believes that the letter
is totally normal because because when
Dees threatens to read it he's like he's
like yeah yeah read it yeah I'm cool
with that it is a love letter of sorts I
think I'm saying that yeah Rob's look to
Caitlyn when uh
there's something lying about speed or
something and he gives her like a little
nod yeah I think you'd be impressed by
my speed yeah whatever look he does to
her is so funny I've never seen him do
it before or since like you know it yeah
yeah yeah he goes he throws a couple of
those looks in in that scene he's got
he's got some great great moments in
this episode there's a really funny
exchange between the two of them Dan
Mack where she calls him out for not
being able to scale the building and
he's like I absolutely could scale this
building yeah she gets in her face yeah
and he's like you think I don't have the
upper body strength and then she gets
and then she gets like literally smushes
her face into his face
here's a joke though that we missed that
I remember wanting and it we didn't get
it
uh so when you cut back to Robin he's
trying to scale the building
Caitlyn's standing right next to him but
the funnier joke would have to have been
to have her off frame so you feel as
though he's halfway up and then like
pull back and see that he's still on the
ground and he's not gotten anywhere he's
got anywhere right I can't remember it
still works one more hilarious exchange
I love in this which is like classic is
then after she tells Mac he doesn't have
the arm strength to scale the building
then Dennis tells him that he doesn't
have the core strength to do it yeah and
then you guys have a whole conversation
about glamor muscles and it was all buys
and tries that conversation is I
remember that bit so funny yeah I
remember us talking about that in the
writer's room and and and Rose martyr
and Roselle getting in on that
conversation it was the first time I'd
ever heard the phrase glamor muscles I'd
never heard that before and I think it
was either Marta or Roselle that was
yeah it sounds like those fearing
commentary on Mac but also on Rob like
yeah exactly kind of pointed just enough
of being like yeah yeah but you guys
talking yourselves into a fury that ends
in a push-up contest
I love the look I love the looks that we
give each other like right before we
drop down to do the push-ups where
there's this like this moment of like oh
[__] we're doing this like he had
seriousness which you describe the flaws
of his workout routine is what's so
funny to me right there's no wink to it
you're like it's dead serious important
information that you're you're doing
your glamor muscles and it's frustrating
and it's frustrating yeah yeah
but I do I also love that that when we
we drop down into the push-ups but then
it immediately cuts to the courtroom and
we're we're doing some push-ups you got
into the same argument there yeah you
did it again yeah it's just good stuff I
you know the with the moment with um
machete and D's face and her pushing her
face back into him I remember not loving
that oh really yeah only because I felt
like it was like too comfortable like I
felt like it's because they're like a
couple in real life she's comfortable
enough oh you felt that that but that's
only because I'm a person who would jam
his face into someone who I wasn't in a
relationship with but I think Caitlyn if
it had been a scene between Caitlyn and
I she would have done same thing
by the way
it's funny I was like I was like is it
too like intimate
intimate yeah yeah
screams right in his face though and
it's funny yeah are you kidding me
I laughed when I saw it again yeah yeah
I absolutely have the upper body
strength to accomplish that are you God
damn it
also there's another example of her like
she does not play that comedically at
all like you look at her face she's
she's [__] serious man yeah she's
like it seems like she's really [__]
pissed at him in that in that moment
luini's saying that he believes that you
shot outside the stadium
no I do believe we shot outside the
stadium the question though is did we
see did we fill in the crowd I think I
think we shot outside of a real game I
mean I I haven't I think we should I
have a memory of that it just seems
unlike I think we schedule it we were in
Philly
we were in Philly and I think we
scheduled it so that we could shoot that
outside of a game so we shot the morning
part then we went and shot all the
frenetic stuff and we might have shot it
kind of in order and then plus you go
you guys got to get all you got to get
your eyes red and and uh you have to get
the the bruising I have to get all the
cuts and the rips in the suit maybe we
shot that at the end of the day
um kind of near the end of the day and I
think the stadium was actually full look
at that I do believe I don't know I bet
that's real
oh wait wait wait wait look to the right
uh see all the people like walking
towards it yeah that's more extras than
we would have
like so you're saying yeah you're saying
those are real people yeah all the
people behind you here
uh all right yeah but see the people
like yeah cross walking towards the
we would never have that many people in
the Deep background like that
I think you're right yeah I know I think
uh yeah I'm fairly certain that was the
real deal
well there you go how did we get though
this location then at like during a game
like or were we just further away from
the stadium then I think we were maybe I
don't know I don't know well I had to
get any location you know what I mean
do you guys do you remember how [__]
hot it was and how like Ponzi almost
[__] passed out in that costume like
when he took the when he took the mask
off he was
it looked like he'd been in a swimming
pool we used to always shoot the show
during the summer and usually get to the
Philly part of the shoot by the end so
we're like August in Philly oh that
green man thing because you're wearing
clothes underneath that too right main
thing's not that but oh no you weren't
huh boxers yeah but I see the boxer
lines yeah I'm wearing like boxers or
underwear or something but no I
definitely had a cup on right so people
don't see your dong uh yeah like six
cups
he's six cups
uh no probably something like that I
don't recall
um but uh no not like a T-shirt and
pants under there anything like that
yeah that'd be pretty warm I miss
shooting in Philly
I do too no the rolling thunderstorms
that would always like come through at
the end of the day yeah
foreign
this show is brought to you by
betterhelp yeah guys it's time to give
online therapy a try right uh you got to
get on your way to being your best self
mag tell people why they should try
better help well have you guys ever
calculated how much time in a week you
spend caring for other people versus
taking care of yourself oofa it's like
all I do yeah good point yeah it's
probably a lot better help is about
making more time for yourself it's
custom built around your schedule it
matches licensed professionals to you
know whatever it is that you're going
through and it's entirely online which
saves you a trip to an office with the
meter parking that's never available so
you have to park down the street but
just kidding because it's a permit
streaks the streets you just like Circle
and circle and circle and circle and
circle and circle again until you
finally give up and risk getting towed
from the grocery store lot that's you
know across the street because now
you're late and you're just already
sweaty and you're paid for the session
and anyway I found better help super
helpful yeah and personalized yeah yeah
how much time did you spend last week
gosh that was more information than any
anyone needed I tell you what just find
more balance with better help right
that's going to do it for you visit
betterhelp.com sunny today that's right
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash sunny and you're gonna
get 10 off your first month
[Music]
did either of you guys play baseball
when you were younger you big baseball
are you asking me if I played baseball
it's for the podcast audience that might
be listening to this episode first we've
talked a little bit about it I played a
ton of baseball yeah
um you played through High School
yeah I played through high school and
then uh in into college uh and didn't
make the team and it was like okay what
was your position what position did you
plus second base hey yeah you and Chase
yeah sure holy [__] and yet Chase is
what six two two I don't know six one
six two he's he's he's at least six foot
that's what happened to me I got to the
college team and it was like uh
first day of like a scrimmage whatever
and um
I was like okay I'm gonna I was up at
bat I'm like I'm gonna get on base I was
fast so I'm like I'm gonna drop a little
bunt and I'm gonna cruise to First and
just get on base right it's useful
totally do it it's great my next at bad
I'm like you know poke a little base hit
uh in the Gap yeah like uh you know just
like a single well their starting
executive basement was like Chase and
size only like thicker he gets like
jammed up on an inside pitch that he
like hits a home run off I don't know
how he does it but he like just kind of
turns on a pitch that's like two inside
and just makes enough contact that it
goes out of the park and I was like oh
I'm I'm done I said I'm gonna be an
actor yeah I should be an actor
um you were you good probably good with
the low balls right and then I was good
at hitting I was pretty good at hitting
and I was pretty good at like uh
Fielding like a ground ball or whatever
but anytime there was an infield fly I
was definitely a little bit like I got
no idea where this thing's coming down
man like I might get this one I might
not you'd lose it in there it's a real
toss-up yeah
you ever catch one in the face the
baseball just straight to the [__]
face no I did that'll turn you off the
game
what
no it didn't break my nose well maybe it
did and I didn't know uh uh but I
remember it hurt like a [__] and
it was a Fly ball and it hit me in the
face and it wasn't even during a real
game it was like but playing baseball
with like my friends like in a just in a
field somewhere and uh
and uh yeah so I was scared of it didn't
I just could never
and I wasn't a uh I was a pretty rough
kid I mean I played football I my
favorite thing to do in football was was
hitting drills I loved the bigger the
guy the better so I wasn't afraid of
like contact I wasn't afraid of
roughness but a a little tiny hard ball
coming at me oh yeah at 90 miles an hour
let's see that was a bit that was a bit
too much it wasn't until high school
that I
stopped being like scared of the ball
but uh so it always scared you a little
bit until High School yeah when I
started wearing a cup
and like lifting weights and stuff I was
like all right I'm fine if this thing
hits me in the chest or whatever I'll be
all right if the hits you in the face
yeah I have a glove I'll catch it well I
mean like you were just not so certain
about that I mean a pitch
yeah that's true
a line drive I'm going to catch you that
pop flies I'm gonna by the way misjudge
it when I was 16 I was an alternate on
our American Legion team
um
well no I was on the team but I like
basically rode the bench I was the
youngest guy on the team and uh I really
would only get in the game if we were up
by 20. and we were really really good
team there's like a lot of talented very
big guys and uh and we won the Rhode
Island state championship which was the
first time that this team from Newport
maybe had ever done it or had done in a
long time I can't remember we're called
R R Construction so and my coach was
Ronald McDonald that's that's where we
got oh that's right his name who was a
character
um
but but uh
I'd say but
Championship right and uh I mean we go
to the um the regional championships we
move up so we're we've
we've beat every team in Rhode Island
and now we're going to play the team
that's beat every team in Massachusetts
a much bigger state
the guys getting off the bus from the
Massachusetts team I think they're from
Quincy Mass just outside of Boston are
it looks like the [__] New England
Patriots these guys are huge and
probably roid it out you know what I
mean like this is like when like roids
are floating around a little bit and
like even if you're a high school kid
you probably get a hold of it um so
these guys demolish they demolish us but
our shortstop
it was a really good player I won't say
his name but like famously would never
wear a cup he was like he was like I
don't wear a cup
well one of these meatballs from Quincy
rips a line drive so hard in our
shortstop and it takes like one bad hop
and drills them right in the nuts
and he's down he's down like they gotta
get an ambulance to like get him off the
field
um so that you know yeah
and I'm thinking like oh this is bad but
am I going in the game
uh no no I was I was worried about it uh
so they yeah so we lose you know we're
that's it you know the the adventure's
over we're getting bust home uh and he's
he's recovered he's like uh you know got
ice and he's back from the wherever and
he's gonna live
and the poor guy the jokes that he's
enduring on the ride home like hey man
it's a ballsy play or like dude that was
nuts or he took a lot of balls to get in
front of that one you know he's like
stop it guys
so yeah so wear a cup does he have kids
I don't know I don't know what's become
of them yeah or what became of his balls
what became his boss what became of his
balls yeah maybe you can tell Meg his uh
real name and we can get our research
department on it yeah you know find out
what happened to his balls oh I don't
know I kind of want to know what
happened to his boss yeah well he lost
one of them for sure
oh man yeah that's the kind of thing
that scared me about that that's why
I mean that scared the [__] out of me
that kind of thing you know what I mean
it just that the ball just kept getting
faster and faster the older I got
I mean and and the size of the players I
mean I like
I knew I was done with football when I
went to summer training
in 10th Grade
I went to summer training
um
and
the kids had just like I just hadn't
really hit that big growth spurt yet I
was maybe still like five seven five
eight
and I was getting on the field with with
basically grown men grown men who were
like 300 pounds and all of a sudden
those hitting drills That I Used to Love
uh I was like oh I'm gonna get my brain
size is a factor in sports for sure but
yeah that's all the more impressive like
guys like uh Dustin Pedroia
um or Jose Altuve
uh I remember going to the Phillies game
and being like wow I'm like the same
size as Pedroia yeah I'm taller than
Altuve and he's like these guys have
been like League MVPs it's the only
thing that matters no but the only thing
that matters Hill is a big part of it
too apparently sure yeah she also didn't
have that but but
I had some of it but not enough but not
enough but in football if you're five
foot seven
and
135 pounds
yeah yeah you ain't gonna make it but
that wasn't that wasn't what I wanted I
wanted I was like a wide receiver or a
running back like I wanted you know I
wanted the glamor positions
more talented at other things than you
could have been athletes maybe but you
pursued a different Talent well it was
that you know it was at that moment that
I realized I was like
I should can just do theater I should do
you think show business is the same way
like like with Pro Sports you can work
your ass off
and you should to you know like the the
guys who make it
it's the combination of the Talent Plus
the hard work for sure right
but like
it kind of like either are or are not
going to be a professional athlete right
it's either like it's yeah it's in the
cards for you or it's not you think show
business is the same thing I I think I
think so yeah I think to a degree look I
think look there's the odd person in
Show Business that just kind of falls
into it right they're like at a
Starbucks at the right time and they've
got the right look and yeah they just
[__] following then you got to be
able to put an audience over yeah as
well right like you find that person in
Starbucks you put them in the movie it's
not just yeah because it's not just
about Talent uh it's not even just about
hard work although it is about those two
things also but it also is about your
ability to accept rejection of which
there is a shitload it's a huge part of
it in this business you have to be able
to withstand a lot of rejection
everybody does everybody even you know
DiCaprio early in his career was dealing
with a lot of rejection you know and you
push if you are the type of person to
push through that you know either
because you just don't listen to dissent
and you're hard-headed or you just want
it so bad that you're willing to push
through it it's like do you want it
enough and I do think that this is one
of those businesses where you really
you have to have a a thick skin
or or a really [__] hard head you
talk about in here um in this episode uh
there's kind of the joke about how uh
Mac is idolizing a player that's
actually younger than him which is like
a weird thing that happens at a certain
point in your life but did you guys have
any like either in sports or in acting
any role models that you've looked up to
like that in such a major way did you
ever write any fan letters or anything
when you were younger well first of all
from baseball perspective uh I idolize
Ricky Henderson uh who like
you play it on the Oakland A's he was
um like the fastest guy in baseball he
has the stolen base record but he was
also an amazing hitter he you know could
hit for power
um
and I don't know why I I honed in on
Ricky Anderson other than he was just a
dynamic really good player and I just
you know I I like had baseball cards and
posters of Ricky and I just like uh I I
remember like I would have like dreams
that like we met in the park and we're
like having a catch or whatever like
much like mac and then I remember going
to a Sox game uh with my buddies Chris
and Carl one time and we see Ricky
Henderson like across the street he's
coming out of the stadium
and I go it just comes out of me I go
Rocky and he like turns he looks at me
like not in a like excited that someone
has barked at him in this way uh and I'm
just like you're the greatest man
that was my yeah
six-year-old
in terms of shows there's lots of people
I'm loving admire guys I think we've
done it I feel like we've done it Rob
how are you feeling do you feel like you
got all your thoughts out and and uh
you've expressed
okay good all right yeah all right so
Rob's feeling good about it and um
you know this is one of the beautiful
things you get to know somebody so well
they don't even need to be here and you
can hear their voice in your head and
you know exactly how they would respond
to things that's pretty special yeah
it's pretty sweet so Rob thanks for
being here today with us uh even though
you couldn't physically be here um your
presence is felt
and the spirit of you is always with us
I think he said [__] you it definitely
said [__] you he definitely told me to
[__] off
that's it that's the show
thank you